[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اليوم ومع بدايه العدوان وممارسه العدو
الصهيوني لكل وسائل الترهيب والارهاب
اليوم وسرته التهجير القصري لاهالي الشمال
الذين نزحوا الى الجنوب املين في الامان
وصل عدد سكان محافظه رفح الى اكثر من
مليون نسمه المنظومه الصحيه في رفح وصلت
الى قاع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحضيض
[موسيقى]
العمليات الجراحيه متوقفه بالكامل نستقبل
في قسم الطوارئ ما يزيد عن ال حاله يوميه
حالات انتشار الاوفه والاصابات الناتجه عن
الحروب بشكل
[موسيقى]
يومي اليوم نقول ان هذا المستشفى وهو قد
اصبح المستشفى الرئيس في محافظه رفع سيخرج
عن الخدمه خلال ايام محدوده في حال استمر
العدوان السولار بدا بالنفاد المستهلكات
الطبيه والادويه في مراحلها الاخيره
الطواقم الطبيه محدوده ومستهلكه
ومستهدف
ه